welcome to another guide for the new
game repo if this video is old check the
descriptions for any updates that may
have changed in these mechanics lastly
all the information this video is from
the games code so
[Music]
enjoy getting started there are three
levels of entities coded into the game
which will be important to distinguish
when understanding enemy spawns level
one entities include the Peeper Shadow
child for Nomes apex predator and spewer
level two entities include Rugrat animal
upscreen hidden Chef bow tie Mentalist
and three bangers level three entities
include the headman robe Huntsman Reaper
clown and trudge all have an equal
chance to spawn in their respective
level so odds of getting a peeper is the
same as a shadow child however 4.66 56%
of the time a level three slot can be
taken up by a set of lower level
entities these sets are limited to three
animals three bow ties three mentalists
two hidden three shf
three upsc screams three Rugrats three
peepers four apex predators four spewers
four shattered Childs six bangers or 10
gnomes just as an example to understand
this a little better a level three
monster such as a clown might instead be
replaced by three animals on a given
level however there can't be two animals
and a chef taking up that level three
[Music]
slot what types of monsters will spawn
will be based off their monster level
mentioned before and the game level you
are on for game levels 1 to two there
will be a level one monster and a level
three monster so for example on your
first round of playing repo you could
get a huntsman just like we did you know
I'm glad you so we're all around the
same same PB got some Goods here guys
what color am I for game levels 3 to 5
there will be one of each monster level
present for game levels 6 to 8 there
will be two of each monster level
present for game levels 9 to 10 there
will be two level ones three level twoos
and two level three entities
and on levels 11 and higher there will
be two level one three level two and
three level three entities meaning
technically the difficulty tapers off at
level 11 monster spawns will not change
during the level so if you get three
clowns be ready to see them for the
entire
[Music]
level when beginning any level entities
will spawn in after 2 to 5 seconds on
the furthest level points from the truck
and be forced to just sit there in idle
for a certain amount of time depending
on the level
shown in front of you are the idle time
ranges for all the levels pause the
video if you would like but the too long
didn't read version is that level one
has the highest idle time at 2 to 3
minutes and then idle time decreases the
further you progress until Level 11
where the idle time hits 0 seconds
regardless of the idle time it will
become active if a player comes within
20 units or a monster plays an attack
audio after 3 to 4 minutes into a level
entities get a short timer that ticks
down when over 20 units away from all
players after which they despawn this
timer is 20 to 40 seconds when the
monster despawns it will be put in a
respawn timer this timer starts at 4 to
5 minutes but gradually decreases as
more time is spent on the level for the
first 10 minutes of the level despawn
entities will be on a 4 to 5 minute
timer and every 10 minutes after the
timer will start to lower until around
50 minutes and higher entities will
respawn almost instantly with their
timer only at 1 second second what can
really help early in the level is that
monsters killed by the player have this
timer multiplied by three so in the
first 10 minutes killing a monster puts
it on a respawn timer for 12 to 15
minutes but killing a monster after 15
minutes will just have it respawn after
3 seconds so in a way it's super
beneficial to play Fast once again
entity spawns will not change for the
given level a good strategy I've been
using is if you have an area that's very
far away from an entity and you want
that entity out of your way you can just
chill in that very far area until the
entity despawns by just waiting that 20
to 40
[Music]
seconds the final extraction is probably
the most dangerous part of this game
when the last extraction for the level
is complete any monsters on their
respawn timer will respawn immediately
and all monsters now have a 1second
respawn timer the monsters will also now
path to the truck room for 12 seconds
after which they path into a room that a
player occupies every 3 seconds so
pretty much as you're running around the
interior the monsters are going to know
what room you're in and they're just
going to patrol that room kind of sucks
we found a good strategy to just send
one player back early before you fulfill
the final extraction and that way you
already have someone at ship in case
everyone dies if you want to catch me
try Harding repo or any other game I
stream every day and a huge shout out to
Shibu for helping me get this
information from the code hope to see
you back in the future for more tips and
repo gameplay